it
is the beginning of october 2020 and so
it's time for another monthly update
video in which we talk about what went
on
in september and what we've got coming
up in october
i always like to begin by highlighting
three big things
so big things for this month no big
surprise for many of those who
know me as a member of the modern
stoicism team and editor of stoicism
today
that all the big things are stoicism
related
so big thing number one uh there's
stoicon there's various stoic on x's i
will be speaking
at at least one stoic on x perhaps more
and i'm the on-deck speaker for stoic
con
just in case anybody drops out or
there's technical difficulties i'm
supposed to jump in and
give a talk so more information about
that in just a bit
big thing number two stoic week which
will be running
shortly after the the big stoichon if
you haven't participated in stoic week
it's a really
excellent opportunity to try to live
like a stoic for a week
and see whether it makes any difference
in your life most people find
out that it does it's also a great
opportunity to sort of
retool i do it every year uh big thing
number three we're organizing a stoicon
midwest as a virtual event
cited officially here in milwaukee just
like stoicon ex-milwaukee
last year but it'll be a virtual event
so it's open to people worldwide but we
will be featuring a lot of things that
do have to do in one way or another
with the midwest so more about that in a
bit
as well the month of september
was as so many an extraordinarily busy
month
in addition to my normal client load
with doing consulting and philosophical
counseling and tutorials
i also started teaching or continued
teaching
six different online classes for three
different institutions
so a lot of my time has been devoted to
to that you know sort of onboarding
students developing content
for those classes i did also do
something that was kind of cool that was
a little bit different than
my my usual stuff i do work in a lot of
applied ethics
but i hadn't done anything with
paralegal ethics and i was asked by the
wisconsin paralegal association
for their annual conference to provide
the ethics training so i did that
and talked a bit about some of the the
issues involved in the codes but also
about stoic practices
and principles and how those could be
useful i also did my usual ask me
anything
session we had our classic metal class
focused on
british metal from the mid to late 70s
and for our worlds of speculative
fiction
series this time around we did ursula
kayla green's
earthsea trilogy videos of all these
except for the paralegal thing can be
found in the video description here so
if you want to check any of these
out go ahead and do so and we had our
usual
um you know half hour hegel sessions
and the stoic fellowship milwaukee sofia
these are all online things that anybody
can join in if they want to
and of course dan and i continued our
radio show wisdom for life
which airs on on saturdays 4 p.m
central we weren't able to do a lot of
new recordings so they were
playing some some re-run episodes but we
did
at least get one in so that that's good
and a lot of that had to do with
workload and illness and stuff like that
so videos uh this month has been an
extraordinarily productive month for me
you might not realize that because a lot
of it's behind the scenes for my online
classes
this semester i am teaching intro to
philosophy
ethics existentialist philosophy
literature world religions
business ethics and biomedical ethics
for some of these i have a lot of videos
already handy but i've been producing
new video content for
some of these classes as well
particularly the biomedical ethics and
the world religions
those i'm not releasing in my main
channel just quite yet
we'll see about down the line how happy
i am with the the lecture videos that i
created with the classes
but you know i have also done quite a
few videos
that i've been releasing particularly on
existentialist thinkers
um kierkegaard's the present age
dostoevsky the brothers karamazov at
least that portion in
book five and lev shestos all things
are possible so those have been from my
existentialism class i did some sadler's
stories
i didn't unfortunately get to the book
reviews or half hour hegel videos that i
wanted to
but i did shoot about over a hundred
course videos so that's that's part of
the reason why
um podcast work i uh continued releasing
the peter singer
episodes on his biological basis of
ethics
then i switched to jeremy bentham his
introduction of the principles of morals
and legislation
then i switched to aristotle's nico
mccain ethics book one and now i've been
releasing stuff on
air common theme to these things they're
all for my ethics class
to provide resources for my students but
you can download them you know just go
to the
sadler's go to my podcast on soundcloud
you can also find it on
a variety of other things including
apple music
and you know google play and you can
download these these
podcast episodes which are from my my
lecture videos but i've taken the sound
and boosted it and taken out all the
um's and odds and
stuff like that um so a lot of podcast
stuff i'm now at 245
episodes which is which is pretty cool
so i i've uh
passed quite a bit oh one other thing
that did happen this month that was
really cool
in terms of video stuff i passed the 90
000 subscribers mark
in youtube so you know i i'm not quite
there to a hundred thousand
um it's been over nine years to get to
90 000
but hopefully we'll beat a hundred
thousand before too long it's kind of a
bragging rights thing i guess you know
doesn't really change anything in any
significant ways
but it's kind of a cool thing so that's
what went on in september
the month of october is going to be
super
super packed and super stoic so you'll
see what i'm talking about in just a bit
let me run through the catalog and
calendar of events that we have
coming up so on the third this coming
saturday
uh i'm at 12 p.m i'm having my monthly
ama that's ask me anything session
uh you can you know start asking
questions now if you want to i'm only
i'm going to try to answer
one per person so don't put a whole
bunch of questions
for yourself because i do want to try to
be fair to the the viewers and
reach as many as possible that same
afternoon on the third
at 2 pm i'll be having my philosophy
chat for
patreon supporters and
that's that's a special perk for them if
you're interested in becoming a patreon
supporter
there's a link that you can click in the
video description and and
do that on the 6th at at 6 p.m that's a
tuesday by the way all these are in
central time
we have our milwaukee sophia that's the
society philosophers in america
monthly session open to anybody you
don't have to be from milwaukee or even
the midwest
to join in we've had some people from
all over joining
in the past on the 7th at 5 00 p.m i'll
have my
hegel q a and discussion session that's
open to the public as well
anybody can join in and then on the
10th we're going to have we're going to
kick off the day
at 12 p.m with the classic medal class
and i'm going to be focusing on the
ethics of tours
past your farewell tour right so tours
of extra
the ethics of extra tours d snyder has
been a real
vocal advocate for not doing that sort
of stuff and he's given some interesting
philosophical reasons why and so we're
gonna
consider that sort of stuff and talk
about what's going on with that
then we we kick off the stoic stuff i
will be
speaking at stoicon x
new england as one of the keynote
speakers
at 4 p.m on on the 10th
that's 4 p.m our time i think it's
five is in the schedule because they're
obviously on eastern time
that is a paid event so you do have to
get a ticket in order to
to do it so if you want to watch it you
you can you can do that
otherwise the the presentation that i'm
doing i'm going to be
uploading into my channel later on as
well so
then uh the 17th another saturday
big stoicon worldwide stoicon there are
already i think 800 people signed up for
it this year
it's going virtual of course because you
know kovid
um and i as i mentioned i'm the on-deck
speaker so
that means that if anybody is having
technical difficulties or
can't do their thing i'm the one who
comes in and gives a talk that i'll
probably have pre-recorded
and then answer questions and all that
sort of stuff so that that's
kind of a big honor i've spoken i've
given workshops at
three of the previous stoicons and um so
you know it's kind of a fun thing the
only thing that
that kind of sucks about the virtual
format is obviously we can't do all the
schmoozing and meeting people and
shaking hands like we
we normally do but it's better than not
having a stoic on at all
then on the 18th the following day 12
p.m
i'll be doing my political theory and
application
sort of hangout and discussion and
this time i'm going to actually focus in
on on stoicism and what stoicism could
provide us as a resource it doesn't mean
withdrawing from the world
as many people's wrong-headed
interpretations of stoicism
would have you think instead it actually
means engagement with your society
and trying to make things better so
we'll talk about the stoic
uh you know virtue of justice and and
what it involves and requires
um on the 24th from 10 o'clock
to four o'clock p.m stoicon x midwest
i will be the mc for the event uh
there's a lot of cool speakers we're
gonna have some
really great panels i will probably
other than you know giving the the
address at the very beginning of it i'm
not going to be
giving a talk but i'm instead going to
be sort of facilitating everything
and we have other speakers to be giving
the the excellent talks that will be
available for you for that and that is a
free event anybody can can do it
uh it'll be we'll be posting information
for it shortly
um on the 29th 6 p.m the milwaukee stoic
fellowship
again virtual so we actually have people
from all over the place
who join us as far as florida and las
vegas
and then finally on the 31st of october
at 12 o'clock and at 1 30 we're going to
be having our next worlds of speculative
fiction
series uh this presentation and
discussion
so that begins with a a youtube video
premiere
of me talking about ursula kayla green
and the rest of the
earthsea books there's you know four
five and six past the trilogy
and then we have uh is that you do live
chat and people talk about the books in
there
and then after that we have a
live discussion using zoom
for people who want to have a more
intensive and engaging
discussion about the books so packed
month a lot of stuff going on
as far as other work obviously i'm still
teaching a lot a lot of things going on
here
and on the podcast i'm going to be
continuing to release more air
videos and then we're moving into
augustine we'll be looking at
book one of on free choice of the will
maybe some city of god material if i get
ambitious enough
then we'll do some aristotle i need to
to release stuff on
nick mccain ethics book two and then
there'll be some stuff
if i get to it on hegel and
self-consciousness and the master slave
dialectic
videos i'm going to be shooting more
core concept videos on lev shestoff
while actually releasing them i still
have one i'd like to get to
if i can and then i've got to jump right
into miguel de una muno's tragic sense
of life because we're teaching that next
week right so my students
need that stuff right away and then
we're doing some i've got a few rilka
videos i didn't get to that i wanted to
last time around
i'm shooting some new stuff on kafka and
if i get super super ambitious
i'm going to do some stuff on kamu as
well i'm going to do those book review
videos that i've been
promising for a while i got to start
doing more half hour hagel so we can
make progress and get through the end of
the
spirit section um obviously there'll be
event videos that you can watch
from from all these cool events that
we've got going on whether they're the
ama
or the the stoic related things and then
i'll do a few more saddler stories for
those who are
are interested in those i'm not sure
quite what i'll talk about yet but
i've got tons and tons of stories i
could probably do those for years
so i'm going to keep those up so that's
what we've got coming i hope you can
join us for some of these
online events like i said video
descriptions
or links all that stuff click the video
description where it says show more and
you'll see all of these things
including the calendar of events so
that's uh that's it for this month hope
you have a great month
and i'll see some of you here in the
interwebs
you